cuáles dígitos podrían reemplazar el
signo de interrogación en la posición de
las centenas para hacer que esta oración
sea verdadera cuatro millares signo de
interrogación centenas veintinueve se
redondea cinco mil si estamos
redondeando al millar más cercano
queremos un número que su millar más
cercano sea 5.000 más cercano de 5000
que de cualquier otro millar
y lo que sabemos de nuestro número es
que empieza con 4000
luego tenemos que llenar la posición de
las centenas y termina con 29 así que
queremos saber cuáles dígitos entre 0 y
9 podemos poner aquí para que este
número resulte más cercano a 5000 que a
cualquier otro millar bueno el otro
millar más cercano podría ser 4000
porque estamos empezando con un 4 aquí y
todos nuestros números van a estar entre
4000 y 5000
así que vamos a mostrarlo en una recta
numérica aquí tenemos una recta numérica
que va de 4.000 a 5.000 y aquí tenemos
marcadas las centenas aquí tenemos
cuatro mil cien cuatro mil 204 mil
trescientos 4.400 y así sucesivamente
hasta cuatro mil novecientos y
finalmente cinco mil así que si queremos
poner los dígitos aquí podemos graficar
los en nuestra recta numérica y ver a
cuál millar están más cerca estás más
cerca de 5000 o están más cerca de 4000
entonces por ejemplo si ponemos un
número justo aquí
cualquiera que sea el número que este
punto representa a cual millar está más
cercano
bueno literalmente está más cerca del
5000 así que lo redondeamos a 5000
porque sería su millar más cercano pero
si por ejemplo tenemos un punto que
estuviera por aquí
su millar más cercano sería 4000 este
punto se redondearía a 4000 porque
podemos ver que está más cerca de 4000
que de 5000 4000 es el millar más
cercano
entonces vamos a regresar a nuestro
número y tratar de poner algún dígito y
ver dónde queda en nuestra recta
numérica vamos a tratar de dibujar
nuestro primer dígito posible con el que
podemos sustituir el signo de
interrogación digamos que cero este
número sería cuatro millares cero
centenas 29 este número estaría entre
cuatro mil y cuatro mil cien
es mayor que 4000 pero no llega a 4100
así que lo podemos poner por aquí un
poco más cerca de 4000 que de 4100
ahora si vemos este número nos podemos
dar cuenta que está mucho más cerca de
el millar más cercano definitivamente es
4000 el 5000 le queda muy lejos así que
el 0 no funciona lo podemos quitar el
cero no es y no sé si debamos probar
todos los números lo que podemos hacer
es observar esta gráfica y ver cuál
sección de esta recta numérica está más
cerca de 5000 y la respuesta podría ser
si encontramos justo a la mitad
aquí 4500
cualquier número mayor a este se va a
redondear a 5000 desde el punto medio
hacia arriba los números se van a
redondear a 5000 así que cuáles puntos
sabiendo que este punto que tenemos aquí
es 4500
cuáles dígitos podemos poner aquí para
encontrar números que sean mayores a
porque cualquier número menor se va a
redondear hacia abajo hacia 4000
entonces podemos intentar y poner un 5
aquí
y 4.529 estaría justo después de 4500
más o menos por aquí este número está
más cerca sólo un poco pero está más
cerca de 5000 así que en 5 funciona el 5
es un dígito que podemos usar que tal el
4 si completamos aquí con un 4
tendríamos 4 mil 429 bueno este número
estaría un poco hacia la izquierda de
4500 esta línea es 4.400 y estas líneas
4500 así que ese punto quedaría más o
menos por aquí lo que hace que se
redondea 4000 está cerca de la mitad
pero está más cerca de 4000 el millar
más cercano es 4000 así que el 4 no
funciona el 5 si funciona y creo que
ahora podemos descubrir la respuesta sin
usar la recta numérica si 4.400 fue muy
pequeño bueno pues el 4300
definitivamente será muy pequeño y el
200 y el 100 y ya vimos que el cero
tampoco funciona y ahora sabemos que el
4.529 funciona
suficientemente grande así que cualquier
número mayor estará más cerca de 5000
cualquier número mayor que 5 en la
posición de las antenas va a funcionar y
va a redondear a 5000 así que los
dígitos que sean 5 o mayores a 5 van a
funcionar aquí van a redondear a 5000 el
6 el 7 el 8 y el 9 son posibles dígitos
que podemos poner en la posición de las
centenas y hacer que este número se
redondea 5000 porque será el millar más
cercano las respuestas son 5 6 7 8 y 9